this video is brought to you by keeps
wisecrack wants you
yes you to watch this video it will fill
you with a tiny morsel of knowledge and
broaden your horizons
so take your mind off the job off your
schoolwork off your life
and succumb to our hypnotizing logo
because
let's be honest what else is there to do
right now
[Music]
what's up wisecrack jared here today
we're going to dive into the work of one
very controversial filmmaker paul
verhoeven verhoeven's films have divided
critics
some call him misogynistic kitschy and
sadistic
others call him a brilliantly subversive
satirist so which is it
to find out let's explore verhoeven's
most divisive films to see if his work
is as deep as his champions claim or as
dumb as his detractors to cry
welcome to this wisecrack edition on
paul verhoeven deep
or dumb and as always spoilers ahead
but before we continue i want to give a
shout out to this week's sponsor keeps
it may be really embarrassing to talk
about but if you're worried about losing
your hair
you're not alone in fact that's probably
everyone's fear
who could pull off a bald head like
dwayne johnson or vin diesel
and the unfortunate part is that two out
of every three guys will experience some
form of male pattern baldness by the
time they're 35.
luckily keeps is an fda-approved
treatment plan for keeping the hair
on your head with keeps you meet with a
doctor online receive a treatment plan
tailored to your needs
and get medication shipped right to your
door keeps offers prescription and
over-the-counter medication and has
doctors on staff to keep track of your
progress
with keeps some men even experience hair
regrowth find out why keeps has over one
thousand five star reviews by going to
keeps.com
wisecrack when you click the link in the
description you'll get 50
off your first three months so check it
out today
and now back to the show verhoven's had
a controversial career from the get-go
he began in the 1970s as a mainstream
filmmaker in his native holland
making provocative work that combined
highbrow melodrama with frank depictions
of sex and violence
however by the 80s verhoeven's films
were condemned by his government for
being too violent perverted
and decadent and for not having an
explicit message
unable to find financing the dutch
filmmaker took his talents to america
where ironically
he would face these exact same
criticisms his american films generally
fit into two camps
violence-filled action spectacle and
sexually explicit dramas
with robocop total recall and starship
troopers verhoeven injected a sci-fi
sensibility into traditional action film
formulas
a revenge thriller a spy adventure a war
film and of course
it's all incredibly violent and when i
say violent i mean this
verhoeven did the same with his dramas
but instead of explicit violence there
was explicit
sex and nudity just look at how much we
had to censor the showgirls clip
and the feedback not great one review of
total recall called it dumber than wwf
wrestling
and innocent of hypocrisy about its
cartoon violence
as for starship troopers the washington
post said it was exactly like star wars
if you subtract a good story sympathetic
characters intelligence wit
and moral purpose and in showgirl's case
the austin chronicles said it was so
shabbily built that it must have been a
cynical desire to cash in on the
public's pervineness
now verhoeven undeniably loves depicting
excessive sex and violence
but is that all there is to his work or
are the critics missing something
as with most filmmakers understanding
verhoeven's intentions
is helpful in deciphering his work
ironically the man who was driven out of
the netherlands for being too extreme
was shocked by american culture to quote
verhoeven perhaps i was naive but when i
arrived in america i was amazed i was
curious about the things that were shown
on television and in cinemas and having
not been in the u.s for that long
i was able to distance myself and look
at american culture in an ironic way
perhaps in reaction to america's
cultural excess verhoen quickly embraced
over-the-top violence in his films
take total recall on the surface the
film appears to be just another big
budget arnold schwarzenegger flick in
which he offs countless goons and saves
the day
but verhoeven amps up the violence to
ridiculous heights
when bullets hit people they explode in
grisly bright red flourishes
and it's not just the bad guys who die
in glorious detail
innocent civilians are mowed down
schwarzenegger even uses this one
unlucky sap as a meat shield
the gunfire shredding his torso into
pieces
the brutality is so extreme that it
becomes in and of itself the point
transforming the film into subversive
commentary on america's fascination with
violence
get ready for a surprise
indeed the absurd violence only
highlights how nonsensical your typical
action film truly is
a fact for hogan himself acknowledged i
have a feeling that making these kinds
of idiotic things
that is total recall robocop superman
spider-man
it's all completely nonsense in the film
douglas quaid an
ordinary construction worker undergoes a
memory implant that allows him to live
out his dreams of being a secret agent
on mars
however during the procedure something
goes wrong and quaids previously
suppressed
memories come flooding back suggesting
that he really is a secret agent
or is he total recall constantly pokes
holes in its so-called reality
when quade goes for his memory implant
the total recall rep tells him that for
two weeks he will get to live out his
secret aging fantasies
people are trying to kill you left and
right you meet this
beautiful exotic woman come on
i don't want to spoil it for you doug
but you rest assured by the time the
trip is over you get the girl
kill the bad guys and save the entire
planet and this is exactly what plays
out in the film
word for word quaid meets an exotic
woman kills all the baddies and saves
the planet
and it all happens in two weeks what's
more when the technician implants quaid
with his memory package he remarks
that's a new one blue sky on mars get
married long and how does total recall
end
with blue skies on mars obviously by
constantly questioning the very reality
of total recall verhoeven draws
attention to the unreality of the
violence on screen
if none of this is actually happening
then you can't take any of the violence
on screen
seriously the violence almost becomes a
joke as of highlighting how silly the
traditional american action film truly
is
but this is only the tip of the
verhoeven subversive iceberg
the filmmakers protagonists all fit the
same basic mold
seemingly moral and upstanding citizens
who turn into instruments of violence at
the drop of a hat and robocop murphy
starts out as a loving family man
well my son jimmy watches this cop show
dj laser and this laser guy does this
every time he takes down a bad guy so
naturally my my kid thinks have a good
cop should be and you don't want to
disappoint
only to become a literal killing machine
in starship troopers a bunch of doe-eyed
teenagers become bug-killing tools of
the government
and in total recall a seemingly normal
average joe becomes
well arnold schwarzenegger perv rehoven
there's a point to all of this
after what went on in the second world
war and we sought what people were
capable of doing to one another
audiences simply wouldn't buy the idea
of perfect heroes anymore
people all over the world were forced to
realize they were no better than the
germans and were capable of committing
similar acts
similarly verhoeven's films show how
easily normal people
just like everyday germans in world war
ii can be seduced to violence
in starship troopers rico rejects the
advice of his father because you're
going to harvard and that's the end of
it
he doesn't want to go to harvard or take
a vacation abroad to a peaceful planet
instead rico wants to join the
federation and kill a whole lot of bugs
similarly in total recall quaid longs to
be more than just an average joe
stuck working a blue collar job don't
you understand
i feel like i was meant for something
more than this
i want to do something with my life i
want to be somebody
what he really wants is to get into the
thick of the action on mars a place of
civil unrest and terrorism
both rico and quaid yearn for the
excitement that only violence can
provide
the exhilaration of killing alien scum
on foreign soil
or shooting up the baddies on a covert
spy mission all these characters need is
a little push
a propaganda pam flint a memory implant
to instantly become the killing machines
of their dreams
in an interview promoting total recall
verhoeven said the film actually depicts
his greatest fear
to quote for hoeven total recall for me
had to do with fear of psychosis
it had to do with the fear a basic fear
of myself
the psychosis is a way my brains could
go when people who behave
nice suddenly turn out to be monsters
and criminals and kill you
by showing how quickly his characters
can be drawn to brutality verhoeven
comments on how we as a society can also
so easily be seduced by violence
in the name of war law and order or even
just because deep down
we like it but that's not all verhovan
doesn't only use violence as a meta
commentary on the absurdity of american
cinema or as a critique of human nature
to really understand his deepest
intentions we have to go all the way
back to his childhood
verhoeven grew up in nazi-occupied
holland where he was exposed to
unimaginable horror
bombings fires and mutilated bodies on
the street
to quote for hoeven i remember seeing
dead people i remember when i was with
my father
being forced to walk past a group of
dutch people who had been executed by
the germans in a reprisal
but young verhoeven didn't realize the
severity of what he was witnessing
and instead detached himself from the
violence later liking the experience to
watching a movie
in rob van shear's biography on
verhoeven the filmmaker recalls
watching houses be blown up burning
across the horizon
he calls the experience less scary and
more akin to watching a particularly
intense special effect
similarly each of verhoeven's characters
detach themselves from the horrors
happening around them
and every day i have to make decisions
that send hundreds of people like you to
their deaths
verhoeven's films are filled with people
nonchalantly watching violence on
screens
robocop constantly cuts the world news
of oppressive governments and insurgency
only to cut to ads for a game about
nuclear war red
alert red alert red alert
in total recall quaid watches people
being shot repeatedly on the news while
drinking his morning smoothie
in starship troopers the news cavalierly
shows gruesome images from ongoing war
hell there are even advertisements for
live executions
execution tonight at six all net all
channels
these films depict a world totally
desensitized to violence
just as five-year-old verhoeven was numb
to the carnage he witnessed
in a meta twist verhoeven uses this
detachment to indict
us because who is more desensitized to
violence than an american audience
munching popcorn laughing and cheering
in a darkened theater as people are
viciously killed on screen
to quote verhoeven people love seeing
violence and horrible things
the human being is bad and he can't
stand more than five minutes of
happiness
put him in a dark theater and ask him to
look at two hours of happiness and he'd
walk out or fall asleep
just look at starship troopers the film
is framed as one long recruitment ad
not for any of the characters in the
movie but for us the viewers
join the mobile infantry and save the
world service
guarantees citizenship
in the film we watch as a bunch of
beautiful carefree teenagers become
gung-ho soldiers
we cheer as rico and carmen shoot down a
bunch of grotesque hideous bugs
save the day and still find love we're
so busy applauding and laughing that we
fail to notice that we're rooting for
the bad guys the idea behind troopers
according to verhoeven was to create a
story that seduced the audience on one
level
but then make it clear to the audience
what they're admiring was actually evil
the troopers in the film are actually
part of a fascist empire committing
genocide against an intelligent alien
race
however hoeven we wanted to do a double
story a really wonderful adventure story
about these young boys and girls
fighting but we also wanted to show that
these people are really
in their heart without knowing it are on
their way to fascism
by getting us to root for pseudo-nazis
verhovan implicates the audience in the
character's crimes
we just like rico carmen and friends are
so easily seduced by flashy images that
we don't ever stop to think about their
context
we're just cute innocent sheep
brainwashed by the deranged images of
fascist violence up on the screen
a similar sentiment is seen in robocop
where the news shows constant images of
chaos and disorder that leave the
characters
and us yearning for some unfettered
crotch shooting street justice
so verhoeven is incredibly deep and the
critics completely missed the point of
his work
case closed right ok we know we know we
still haven't addressed the elephant in
the room
a movie so reviled it won the razzy for
worst picture
a movie so bad even the people who like
it tend to do so
ironically yes i can only be talking
about the one
the only showgirls
okay but here's the thing showgirls
actually isn't that far off from
verhoman's previous films
just as the director critiqued violent
action films and show girls the
filmmaker goes even broader
turning his sights on the entertainment
industry as a whole
showgirls is the quintessential rags to
riches hollywood story
a woman with nothing to her name works
her way up to become a star
this is the same story every hollywood
wannabe dreams about
move to la make it big in the movies and
become famous
except in showgirls verhoeven shows how
rotten the stream truly is
instead of centering his film around
hollywood verhoeven transplants this
narrative to the glitzy artificial
las vegas instead of making it big in
the movies nomi works her way up from
dancer to background showgirl to star
showgirl
but all that glitters is not a gold
nipple tassel
verhoeven makes sure that nomi's ascent
is anything but glamorous in fact
there's hardly any difference between
the low-level strip club where nomi
starts out and the flashy high-end las
vegas showroom where she ascends to
stardom
both places are driven by the same
craven commerce
sex as verhoeven puts it with showgirls
the attack on vegas for example was that
everything is bottom line
and that sexuality is only another thing
you can sell for the highest price
everything in showgirls is a sexual
transaction from the driver who picks
nomi up expecting a little something in
return you can sit a little bit closer
if you want
to the man who pays nomi 500 for a lap
dance to the boss who nomi sleeps with
in order to secure a role
as her archrival crystal says you are a
[ __ ] darling
no i'm not we all are
we take the cash we cash the check we
show them what they want to see
but nomi constantly tries to fight this
commodification
insisting that she won't sell her body
but by the end of the film she realizes
the truth that her dream job
becoming the star of a vegas show is yet
another exploitative sexual transaction
your face is gonna be up on billboards
you're gonna make a lot of money for the
stardust whether she's dancing at the
strip club or posing on a giant
billboard it's nomi's body that's making
her money
faced with such a realization nomi spits
in zack's face and walks away from the
show
as for the actual commerce of the film
verhoeven lampoons our cultural
obsession with sex
just as he did with violence by
gratuitously going over the top
so over the top in fact that we can't
show you the scene where nomi gyrates
around to an absurdly comical degree
here the sex just like the gore and
total recall on starship troopers
becomes designed to incite laughter it
too is a part of the joke
and every aspect of showgirls is in on
this joke the film's excessive
over-the-top style
is used to lampoon the quintessential
golden age hollywood musicals
but while old hollywood had lavishly
choreographed classy song and dance
numbers
showgirls has lavishly choreographed
buck ass naked gyrating that again
we can't show you what's more it mocks
the competitive dog-eat-dog nature
ubiquitous in films about big hollywood
dreams by again
taking the genre to absurd extremes in a
conversation between rivals nomi and
crystal
they bond over both enjoying dog food
growing up
literalizing the two as dogs fighting
over the same bone
i used to love doggy chow
i used to love doggy chow too but who is
the ultimate target of this joke
yet again it's us we are the audience at
the cheetah lounge who can look but
never touch
we who pay money to see the same
recycled hollywood stories over
and over again we who can't help but
vicariously get off on the wanton
violence and sex depicted on screen
when the light's dim finally we can
indulge in our true debased selves
so we're going to give verhoeven's work
or at least this portion of his work
a certified wisecrack deep with no
reservations
but what do you think wisecrack is
verhoeven brilliantly roasting our
gluttonous desire to consume
outrageously graphic material or are we
trying way too hard to justify watching
this
[Music]
let us know in the comments big thanks
to our patrons for supporting the
channel and our podcast
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button as always catch you next time
guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you